the Joe Rogan experience the reason why
I recommended for us a hobby is first of
all he's one of the smartest guys I've
ever talked to for us is it [ __ ]
genius legitimate genius knows
everything about MMA I mean there's not
a stone unturned and he coached GSP and
I feel like your style and GSP style are
very similar and that you both are very
good wrestlers and you're both very good
at mixing up the wrestling and the
striking where you don't see anything
you don't know what's coming and you're
both you don't both don't have any
weaknesses you have an awesome
submission game GSP has an awesome
submission game you have great wrestling
great striking it's very similar and I
think that his experience and coaching
one of the greatest of all time in
Georges st. Pierre would would lend
would just slide right into coaching
someone like you I really believe that
yeah I think for rock as I'm getting
closer to it you know I'll know more
when I when I get there but that's the
last stop
yes opponent was the best stop and kind
of the longest of it - yeah I had
already thought that if I was a young
man and I was thinking about fighting I
think I'd moved to Montreal yeah I think
he's got a special mind mm-hmm I do you
know and I and it's not to take away
from any of the brilliant coaches I mean
I think you could be a world champion
with Duke Rufus who's also brilliant guy
and an amazing coach I mean there's no
bad stop for you
but there's just something about you and
for us a hobby that I just feel like
yeah when I met him and I said next time
we had dinner together as soon as I sat
down next to him he told me everything I
did wrong in a Tony fight like right out
the gate I was like bingo right
I mean he's but he's genius sharp he's
smart yeah so yeah I mean but then again
Wittman I've worked with Wittman - and
Wittman is really experienced dude you
know he's coached so many people he's
seen so many different styles and done
it himself a lot - so I love about
Wittman when just engaged he flatlines
people Whitman acts like nothing even
happened yeah it's like he knew it was
gonna happen it's crazy like everybody's
jumping and cheering Whitman like yep
I think it's cuz he's seen so many been
on the the other side of that to where
you know it's your guy
knocked out two so sure you know it's
like you said it's two people going in
there somebody's gotta lose so he's been
around the game long enough to where he
understands the other side of it too
that's you know you ain't gonna go crazy
and yeah you know yeah cuz that guy's
got a family that guy's got people that
he's trying to take care of he's got
every other motivation that you got to
you know yeah yeah really yeah um I
think the alt is also the culture shock
or moving to Montreal will be good for
it too
yeah I mean maybe uh I spent some time
it's cold as [ __ ] oh my god I've been
Montreal in January it's like outside
you get that thick fog coming out of
your mouth that's why I'm going to Joe
yeah go in June but look good for you
man I think it's good for you I feel
like that that cold might it might be
something today you know the best
wrestlers and everything are always from
the Midwest and from that cold and you
know why they developed character yeah I
think it is some today you know a
hundred there's not as soft as people
out here in town by all my friends from
Boston they come out of California
people are [ __ ] soft out here yeah you
know if the shovel snow and have to
worry about freezing to death you know
if your car breaks down in Boston you're
ten miles from your house you might
freeze to death
yeah that's real that's real you better
keep a blanket in that bench yeah yeah
you have to be tough and sleeping bag on
a candle you know and I think it gives
you like different different morals and
different like yes different character
to you you know you you you you value
things a little bit differently so in
that cold you know Detroit the same way
that's like seven months out the year
you spend in that time indoors and in
New Deal's like your family and
everything cuz that's you ain't gonna be
inside with some [ __ ] of Schmo from
down the street and you don't wanna you
know I to count on each other to when it
gets [ __ ] cold
[Applause]